よし、やるか
もうこの組み合わせがめずらしいよね
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーと、
東海オンエアのりょうです。
というわけで今ですね、
東海オンエアが全員むりやり僕んちにきてるんですけども、
むりやりじゃない
今みんな仲良くゲームをしたでやっております。
で、まあ　てつや、あの子スマホが大好きなんでね、
大好き
モンストとか、もうずっとゲームをやってるらしいんで、もう良くないと。
うん、最悪壊したい
壊したい、という意見も、メンバーからきているので、
僕がちょっとバシッと
やっぱり、スマホにとらわれてちゃ、だめだと思うんです。
バシッと、1発痛い目に合わせようと思ってるんで、
今回ちょっとこういうものを準備いたしました。
足つぼマッサージってみんなしってます？
知ってます
知ってるっしょ
そのマッサージなんですけれども、
もはやいてーよ、と
これおかしいでしょ　完全に表記がおかしい
足裏いてーよ、と
もう痛いともう断言しているやつらしいです
うわっこれやばいで
ああ痛そう
サイズがおかしくね？
う～わ　やばい　おかしい、もう
ちょっと一回のってみますね。
うヴぁ～
無理だ、これが無理
これだ、
マジで痛い
これを、ちょっとたくさん準備したんで、
今回の作戦としては　僕が、てつやのスマホ水に水没させようとします。
シンプルにね、目の前で
めちゃめちゃ焦る　めちゃめちゃ焦る　絶対焦る
ほんとにやりかねないと思ってるんですよ　たぶん
てつやのスマホを水没させようとしてる瞬間を、
てつやの目の前でやります。
ただ、その、僕とてつやの間には、足裏いてーよが、
つらなっている
てつやが、スマホを助けるためには、足裏いてーよの上を
全力疾走しなくてはいけない
絶対絶命の状況を作ってあげて、痛い思いをしてもらおうと、
してもらいましょう
どれほど彼のスマホに対する気持ちが強いかどうかを
確かめてみようと思います。
はい、というわけで足裏いてーよがたくさん準備できましたので、さっそく仕掛けていきましょう。
では、ひいていきましょう
なんかちょっと近いね、うん近い。
準備は完了したんで、　あとは僕が水を持って、てつやのスマホを
パクってきてすぐあそこに行きます。
一回上走らなきゃいけないじゃないっすか
ああーっ（ゲームしてる人の声）
ああーっじゃない…
じゃあ、りょうくんが、とってきて走って俺の方にスマホ投げて、
ＯＫっす　ＯＫ
これに、落としてやりましょう
あーれっ？
あぶないっ　危ない　早く早く　あ危ない
早く　やばいやばいやばいやばい
え？なに？え？
全然分からん　全然分からん
全然分からん
あれ？おまえスマホわ?
はっはっはっはっは
耐えて来るんだここまで！
なにっ？痛って痛って痛ってえっ？えっえっ何？え？
意外と走ってこれたね
ふっふっふっ
意外と強いね。
いやいやいやいや
あれえ？
ばか痛い
何そっ
ヴぁーっヴぁーっ
あいっだぁあ